we're getting 100 on this one i know  we're gonna throw everything in the  kitchen sink at it like because the  first two movies we really had to stay  honest to like what  the reality of the dancing in that world  is and it's you know it's not like the  best dancing in the world but it's fun  jan's gonna become the pt barnum of  stripping  i'm in uh every day for three hours a  day in in a garage in the valley we  always laugh because like if anybody  ever came by and like looked into this  garage and to see what we're doing like  saturday morning i don't even know what  i don't i can't even describe to you  like what we're doing is that woman on  top of that yeah  daddy what are they doing like yeah